multiple axis plots
okay
okay hi everyone we are continuing our
design review of visualization for
version
13 of wolf language
and i know from experience this morning
that this is our 501st live stream
design review
um
okay
by the way have we finished on
everything to do with vector
displacement plot
i think so yeah i think so
okay
let me just bring up the
christopher did you ever see these let's
list vector displacement plot yeah i saw
yes yes
do you have any comments on them since
you have it i know you said there's no
list version yet
so
yeah no i i don't have any comments
about them
okay
do you have a use for them christopher
or yeah well i have a pretty complicated
use or like a use that involves um
a bunch of you know geo positions being
you know
the basically the displacement of a
bunch of geo positions actually they're
astro positions and then trying to
display that um but yeah
and there isn't a geo
version of this right
no
and
we actually
didn't hadn't actually even planned one
but
maybe there is a use case for it
i think continental drift i could
subscribe
so stephen i just sent you a notebook
with some multi-axis
okay starting points
so
okay do we have people from design here
we have jeremy yep okay great
all right
okay the question is what what are those
things called in military you know
otherwise when people have all those
stripes and things what on earth are
those called
regalia maybe
are they bars
yeah bars sounds right okay in any case
this seems like okay so the main issue
and
is that when are we getting enough
activity
enough interactivity of these plots that
you can click one of these
and have something light up
i expect to have that
for this functionality in 13.
so in other words what you're saying is
the axis will light up when you click up
a curve yes yeah it will turn black or
you know slightly bolden or something
okay
it'll probably go both ways
you know so that you would like perhaps
click on the axis and the three curves
associated with it in this case
would get thicker as well okay so anyway
the the thing that's happening here
is
okay
what happens if the
y-axis is also a multi-axis play
you mean the x
x-axis sorry it's also right we're not
handling that case yet but but that
gives you know a good reason for
wanting something that lives
you know sort of parallel to the axis
instead of
you know at an end that
runs along it or in the middle or
something
okay but what's the syntax for for x
multi-axis
um it gets a more
annotated
um
in what way
in that you basically would have to say
you know curve one
you know
x you know goes to this curve one y goes
to that
sorts of things
or i mean actually probably we would do
a grouping of here's what the x you know
groupings are and here's what the y
groupings are well so but you haven't
figured that out so let's figure that
out
so you're saying
here
these are
the
left y
axis but now what about what have i
given actually this one doesn't give
where the axis is placed it just says
which ones are um
in one axis the first group says one
axis one two three
next axis is four or five it doesn't say
where the axes are
by the way this is cut off on the left
yeah
resize the graphic i have a bug filed
about it so
okay but what on earth does this i mean
these things went in random places but
what does this mean and why did it pick
so it has a left bias so you have three
axes to it but two on the left and one
on the right
sounds political
never mind
um
i mean we could look at like language
and flip it for you know people whose
systems are
no no i'm i'm joking yeah i have a mind
i am too
um
okay
but but why did it put
the
first ones of these closest in
it's not what i would have expected
uh
so there is no language right now i mean
so we can discuss defaults but do we
need to design a language for where to
place axes
do you think that's important
in this first preliminary release
i didn't think this is the much most
important case
but i don't quite understand the syntax
here anyway
um this just says
the length of that list says how many
axes you have all right
i understand that
this is how does this relate to the
whole filling business
this way you also slam into jobs yeah i
know
um
well i mean look okay
so you're saying
each one of these is an access
yes
um
sander on livestream is saying i'm
surprised as a highly requested feature
in my field i've never seen such a plot
you know what as you get closer to
physics i think these plots become less
and less common
i suspect
that it's sort of a function of cost of
publishing in the old printed days or
something
no i think multi-axis blocks have become
more common i think they have become
common
in you know
it's a weird thing honestly and it's in
fields where it matters what the units
are and things like this and i i don't
know i mean people plot the most crazy
things on the same axis
yeah i think they're very useful to have
at the same time i i i'm not sure i've
ever really seen a use of a multi-axis
plot where it didn't seem like an abuse
of a plot of plotting two unrelated
things on top of each other but
that's a different issue
yes
well
you know our goal is to have it you know
right
okay so let's let's just review what it
is that this means
so is this the four or is this the five
that went on the left
uh the four
and where did the five go
it's on the right
with its
with its bars hidden
yes the bars
rendering in the wrong spot okay fine
so wait so it goes it goes
the left edge it goes left left right
is that kind of what happened here
yes
okay and what if i just seven would it
go left left left four times and then
right right right or would it go back
and forth or something
so this is a pretty nice case
right i mean at the moment
it says
hey i have k axes
i'm going to put
half of them on the left
half of them on the right
and if there's an odd number
the extra one is going on the left side
what happened
but the ordering is going to be the
first half or on the left it's not going
to alternate or something
um
that's probably some error checking on
my part if you do range five it should
be
oh my
what happened there
so it didn't bar itself or maybe that's
because the version i have is different
from the version you have well i mean it
has
some flexibility
on and
i think you didn't like this style no i
know so let's talk about this for a
second because i mean this
these bars are pretty hard to read
in my opinion
um
jeremy got any brilliant ideas here
well
the bars don't mean anything without a
legend though
yes they do because
no i mean their identification
right because they represent the green
curve goes with this axis
that's the idea
right
it's like like in this case it's fairly
clear that if you want to know green
values
you look at the green axis
values for the green curve you look at
the green axis okay
um there are probably some colors though
that people use for the curves but where
it's very hard to read the numbers
right so here's a question we could take
the hue and we could darken it
like for the axes what do you think
jeremy what do you think of that is that
crazy
or we could have the numbers not be in
the
we could have the the um you know the
axis being that color
that's completely possible that's but in
this case here
you are multi
this is multiple axes right
right well multiple curves on a single
axis
right which in this case oh i see this
case i didn't ask for but now what would
happen if i had um
if i had something where i said in in
this scheme
one two three
four for example
oh it blows up again
i'm saying closing brace
no wait a minute so somehow
in some cases i'm getting colored axes
in some cases i'm getting
i'm very confused here in some cases i'm
getting regalia
resist so if you have any access
that has multiple colors associated with
it
on all of them oh my gosh
oh my gosh
my head exploded here yeah right
um
then
okay
all right let's let's
let's look at these alternatives
sandra is favoring dots and i agree the
dots are much more natural looking i
think these bars are just weird
my concern or any concern i have with
dots
is
you know there are going to be cases
where we're going to
i think have to use a line
yeah yeah particularly if your curves
differ
if they're black like dashing
yeah or something
oh gosh
okay okay let me understand this so
with color i mean this seems rather
elegant
yeah that was i think your favorite you
know thing that you were proposing on
friday
wait the bottom one i mean if you're
using list plot you can't even tell if
those are points in the plot or on the
axes
i'm not the best sitting right on the
axis
i think they can sit right on the axis
with the list plot
if you have
no plot range padding and
yeah or or you said a plot range even
yuck
but but i mean but i think as as roger's
probably saying i mean it's like
we have a consistent way with the
legends for representing you know points
lines dashed lines etc
and you know it might be kind of weird
if we just have a totally different
system for this
well the question is how does
what this is doing if we have legends
let's remember how legends do it
um
well let's see if we if we say well
if you use that example at the top
okay
so make a copy of that get rid of the
plot layout you know turn plot layout
into plot legends goes to automatic
sorry get rid of the plot layout
what those ugly things
that's those are placeholders you can
edit
yeah
because we don't have any other
[Music]
so now if you said something like you
know joined arrow you know i don't know
you set some of them would be joined and
something would be false the ones that
you'd say false they'd show up as dots
not as lines
right
i meant so if i say joined does join
take i didn't even know it did that true
false
true and it'll just repeat if you give
it a shorter list
okay
oh that's nice
i think it's the same with dashed and
stuff like that
okay so how does that work if we say um
plot style duplo goes to dashing
dashing dashed one of those two
dashed lines there
those are very big
those are very big
that seems wrong
yeah
well this is the i think what happened
to the fighters that showed the dashing
that's a mistake
i mean i think that's two one third
thirty percent longer than it needs to
be
but maybe if they're different dashing
patterns that's what you have to do
anyway the points are too big and that's
just a bug
yeah
um
okay so is there an analogy to this that
could be done
for
axes
you know
we've got a vertical axis here normally
if it had an access label
the axis label would say x and it would
sit off here right
normally it would be at the top but yes
for an axis
okay
how do i get the thing to go on the side
uh at the moment that's only with frames
um
as we're switching stuff over to axis
object then it would be placed but
nothing to show there yet
okay
but so
okay so you're putting
that label there all right so the
question is where do we put
the indicator
of which axis
is referring to which
line
um
well ideas guys i mean i personally i
think it's going to be better off at the
foot than at the head
whatever we do here
my problem with the i mean i i like the
foot but we tend to have
you know that bottom axis i mean so so
we're using a frame in that case
and you're going to have other tick
labels down there
[Music]
already
i
it's going to get a bit crowded
well how do people do this in the
literature typically
badly um you know so they change the
axis style
they
rely on the reader to be able to figure
out which accounts yeah i know i've seen
plots where it's just completely unclear
which cover it goes with which access
right
um i mean really unclear like you have
to way too many of those plots in fact
guess you have to guess based on values
which uh it's crazy right or based on
the actual caption saying you know this
increases as this decreases
exactly um
by the way we should give people the
opportunity to do that piece of insanity
we should not encourage it but it
shouldn't be impossible
okay to not label the axes
it's really disgusting and should be
avoided but
um
okay
all right so let's take a look here so
what what options do we have
we could run it along the axis
i mean
okay so so the super simple solution is
to not allow multiple curves per axis in
which case our job is much simpler
what we do in that case
well then in actually the one where each
axis is styled
yeah
in some way but but what does jeremy
think of this
i so far i like the dots the styling
worries me um
i i guess color takes care of it but
when you get to black and white that
falls apart like
i said dashing on that is going to be
yeah really ugly well let's let's look
at what it will look like i mean in this
case here if i say
plot theme
arrow
dashed lines
that's really what works
[Laughter]
wow it's kind of impressive but weird
yes a little weird
a little weird i have to say it works
better than i thought it yeah me too i
thought yes i think this is an
interesting
you know honestly
for
non-publication purposes this actually
is pretty nice
i mean if i was just doing it as a
practical
sort of
you know see what's going on i'd like
this
jeremy what do you think about darkening
the colors for the axes is that crazy
some minimal darkness value some of
those you don't need to darken and
they'd get worse like the blue probably
is worse darkened but the yellow yeah
and the green looks like it could what
about what about changing the um color
of the um
uh the actual
probably the same where you wanted the
same color to match the darkened color
no no i understand i mean i i like
steven's idea of we go ahead and style
that you know the line in the axis
but not the text we leave the
tick
i've got another crazy idea guys okay
my idea is
what if so right now the access is a
gray line okay
maybe this is crazy but
what if
this thing became
the gray line as well as a colored line
like two lines next to each other two
lines right smushed next to each other
okay can we can we simulate that easily
i mean what we would get
with a tiny offset with offset by the
thickness of the lines
maybe that will look ridiculous
jeremy what do you think
i i'm gonna try it no i don't think
that's a bad idea also maybe the ticks
are gray but the line isn't they don't
know
the ticks don't necessarily need to be
the color right i mean maybe the right
thing to do what i'm thinking is the
ticks and the numbers are gray
and what happens is it has a cladding so
to speak of the color next to it
and if it's a multi-curve thing it can
be clad in different colors as you go
down the
axis
well the problem with the cladding is is
dashed would do that as well like you
can do dash between multiple colors and
it'll look the same
wait a minute
but i'm saying if you put in cladding
here the cladding can have be dashed or
not
wait are you talking about something
okay if you had multiple colors one
option is that you just have multiple
lines all right next to each other like
on like a subway map kind of thing right
where there's offset by the thickness of
the line no another option
i'm suggesting that you
that it goes part way
that if there are two at half of the
cladding the top half of the cladding is
is orange the bottom half of the
cladding is green the cladding is still
a line that's like immediately adjacent
to the gray axis line right what i'm
suggesting is the cladding
is
you have the gray line then you have the
cladding then you have the tick labels
jeremy can mock it up see what it looks
like
um
all right that's a possible idea
and that that way we get
i mean
yeah
i mean i i suspect we also should offer
some styles
that work differently for example the
style in which
who knows i mean
ethan recommends a thing called txe what
the heck is taxi i've never heard of txc
it is a
latex drawing package
okay i think
well i don't know if there's anything to
learn from it i strongly suspect they
have not addressed difficult problems
like this the general thing we find is
that
that
you know when it comes to difficult
problems
the
the atmosphere gets thin very quickly
um
yeah the whole
um
could you do plot theme our dashed lines
on the multiple
plot
per access
i'm sure it will do something
what the heck would this do if you did
multiple plots but oh i see this will
this will presumably put your
your regalia
with appropriate dashing and so on up
there right you can try it you can you
had something if you just copy the
multi-axis spec below
you know where you're manually sure i'm
but i don't think it's going to be
i'm not a big fan of that but but okay
so we can say one two three four for
example
okay so there we've got regalia and
multiple
i see that we're just having regalia
we're not having
clad axes i'm really not going for this
regalia thing i don't think it works
anybody disagree with me here
i maybe disagree a bit like i mean i
just think it's much
it's it's
i mean
one it's definitely a bit less hokey
than the kind of
colored axes and also
i think it's just more in line with how
legends work everywhere else
or do you think it should be at the top
or the bottom
i don't know i mean i don't know how it
would interact for example with a plot
label that's at the top usually
but
not that i like plot labels at the top
i'm looking forward to plot label out of
placed is that coming
not for 13 i think
so if you scroll down while jeremy's
mocking stuff up
you know there's
variations with the regalia and other
you know aligned differently
well i think this is a better alignment
than that one
that's freaking weird
in my opinion
okay
you don't have anything now
okay here's a question
you know what about go to the next one
because i think it's close to your
cladding idea
well i think that's better
i think that's better it's like it's
like labeling this you know x y z
i think that's better
yeah i like that one too
and this one being pointed out that's
just not going to work because it's too
confusing with with points
okay let's let's wait for jeremy to get
that mock-up and let's go on to the next
item and i think is the is this the main
thing we still have to decide with
multi-axis yeah i view this as sort of a
first and we could call it i don't know
how we do experimental with a sub
feature to a function but i thought we
had a way of tagging that
i i think we we did it with the
um
vector geo stuff
where that was sort of a setting that
was experimental i just want to talk
about this this thing here um
so
the issue is in principle
boy
we've got axis positions and we've got
curves
and in a sense what we have to do is map
you know
look i mean we could say we could have a
syntax where we say left arrow
one two
we could do this we could say
this means
two left axes with those curves in them
and probably in that order going left to
right
exactly
so outside it
that's correct well yeah but for right
it should go
from left to right as well that would be
super confusing what's that
reading order
yes
yes so it'll be totally confusing if it
went the other way yeah um
and then that extends to bottom and top
eventually
yes i think so but i would say that i'm
not keen on having this plot layout
multi-axis i would be much
um
you know i would have thought this
should be
something like um
well is it axes positions or is it frame
positions
does this work with axes or only with
frames
and it's really a frame thing
okay um i mean i have seen people do
you know where they don't draw like the
top frame edge in a case like this
and so it really would be the
right
or frame
frame axes what do we have
what do we want to call this i i think
this should be its own option i don't
think it should be hidden inside a plot
layout
i'm i'm fine with that i i want to make
that also experimental so because the
only thing i want to get in before we
nail it finally is a more deployment so
we see more problems
yeah i agree
but okay so what should we call this
option this is the option that basically
says
where to put
okay what are some similar options
there's there's scaling
um what is that called what's that
called plot
i'm losing my mind a-link functions oh
scaling function yeah
right
scaling functions okay that's a
different thing but this is i mean
scaling functions could be different for
different curves could they not what
happens with these axes when one is
logarithmic and one is not
or is that considered insane
i mean i don't think it's insane but
it's not in the current scope
i mean at the moment scaling functions
is
you know a plot-wide
option
okay so if i said scaling functions here
scaling functions arrow well logs
probably going crazy but that's okay
let's do reciprocal
i was gonna say that's probably even
crazier but
i don't think it did
did it do anything
i guess it did okay the axis on the
right
maybe do log because then we can
actually see if it i mean the the the
scaling functions aren't going to be
reflected in the axis yet
oh that's just
as a bug matter well they are yes they
are
well
the reversal of the scaling is not
reflected yes those are the absolute
values of the scaling
exactly
okay
maybe in the same vein though as as
interaction with other options how does
um has it already been resolved how plot
range works with this
no
because presumably you need you need one
you need one x spec for every axis right
or like one y spec for every axis right
right i mean so the way that would work
would be like how it does for
parallel axis plot where
you list out rules
one goes to you know zero to ten two
goes to whatever whatever
for plot range
okay so now
maybe parallax squad already does this
as well but but also you presumably need
some way of specifying how they line up
with each other
right like if for example you wanted the
zeros to align
good point
how does parallel axis plot do that
um the alignment is
you know
the bottom you know ends of the plot
ranges are at the bottom and the top
ends of the plot ranges are at the top
so you can use plot range to you know
it's a little bit it's a little bit
manual but you can use plot range to get
everything where you want it
right
you're basically setting you know what
the access range is for
each axis
okay is that documented in the plot
range thing that that for parallel
access plot so that that would
presumably be the exact same story here
well except you have the x and the y
situation
which i mean one i mean the rule syntax
is plot range does plot range document
this case for parallel access plot no
sploth
why not
because it's very specific to parallel
axis plot and radial axis plots but it
should have a note that says that
otherwise people are going to get super
confused
okay here's jeremy's cladding
i don't think that looks that bad
i think this looks better than this
oh this is the other way around from how
you explain it steven but this looks
better no it doesn't
no this is what stephen was describing
okay i thought that you wanted the
axes and ticks to beat of color no no
there was that too but
he wanted a colored line parallel to the
axis line i see
and i i would argue that actually this
one might look slightly better with the
with the cladding on the inside
well then they would block the ticks one
now you're overlapping ticks it'll be a
problem especially short ticks
but then this would go on the outside as
well
i like this i mean maybe uh maybe this
case
is an optimal case for it but i i like
this now what about double cladding
multi-cladding
do
would one multi-cloud with with uh
multiple multiple lines there it would
look just fine yeah
and what about with dashing
again dashing i don't think it's gonna
look that bad it might look a little
weird for example here's a case that
would look weird if it's all black and
white and you have different
shades of you know different flavors of
dashing next to each other that's where
the bottom is probably better
you get and enough to understand what's
going on but it's not distracting at
least when you get up to this top of the
plot
well but right but i mean but then then
you'd have to stack them right if there
are multiple things per per axis you'd
have to stack the clouding elements
might not be too bad
i think it's more concern i like this
better than this this is visually
distracting to me
actually though i mean both
i think
right in the case where you have
different dashing styles and it's all
black and white i mean i think if you
had them next to each other it would
probably look very strange but also if
you had them one after the other like in
some sort of the bottom half is this
dashing style the top half is another
dash style
that could also be really confusing yeah
that would be an obvious break
right they would have to be broken apart
which is possible you could have things
of that i think even with colors you
might want to do that in that case yeah
you do want to break them apart i don't
think you want them right next to each
other
um
well so i mean i guess the question is
then which is better is it this or the
version that we saw above where it was
just like a little sample that was to
the left of the numbers
i don't know how i prefer this i
significantly prefer this i think this
looks a lot cleaner
this one makes me feel like double
vision's kicking in or something
yeah that's my only concern like when
i'm i'm looking at it on a smaller
screen right and at first i thought the
lines were blurry
well look we could give people
particularly we can give people options
i mean there's
no with that we've got to name the
options though
i mean and the other thing is it's like
you know the case where we have actual
labels associated with the curves
and because they're you know association
keys or plot labels or something
it's probably going to kick into
you know something
slightly different closer to
you know the other one where the stuff
is
to the left of the things because
it will be like the legend where
you have a line swatch and
the label perhaps
also one other detail is what about
points like what about if it's not
joined
do you also just show a line yeah yeah
you show a line i think
i think so okay
think so
[Music]
uh
is it possible to have two different x
axes someone else the answer is not yet
but it will be
i mean that will get very very weird but
i mean look we're dealing with corner
cases here i mean the most common case
is going to be
so wait a minute let's look at the most
common case the most common
cases some
lines are associated with the left axis
some lines are associated with the right
axis
in the most common cases you have two
curves
and one's on the left and one's on the
right
okay and there we would do cladding for
that by default that the right idea
okay sure
i think that'll look pretty decent
um
fine and then we can have options for
right now method options of some kind or
something um
and we can call this i don't know
cladded axes or something versus
swatched axes or something like that
versus swatches
i have no problem coming up with names
so
okay let's let's understand the name of
this option here
so what is this option this option it
says which curve is associated which
data set
is associated with which access
maybe we should call it multi-axis
because then we can
that can sort of expand to the
multi-axis arrow automatic
right for instance
that would be one but then your setting
up there would be an example of a
setting
sure
i see in other words you are defining
the multi-axis
um
if you set multi-access to anything
well multi-axis false would be there
aren't any multi-axis right now
yeah
is that the right spelling of multi-axis
that's a question for you
yes
i was using capital a for a long time
and then
i you know
i mean and so like you know if you
like that plot layout command that you
have right below where you're typing
you know it is case insensitive with
regard to the a
well okay so multi-axis i would buy
multi-axis
i like i like what you did first multi
camel case plural axes
because
i don't know framax well frame ticks
i mean we have things that go both ways
i think in singular and plural
so on on the google google engrams
viewer it looks like multi-axis with a
lowercase a is more popular for what
it's worth well then we should be using
it because words always smoosh
exactly
english is becoming german and swedish
yeah
all right
it's commenting that one thing you can
do is to color i think it's pretty ugly
but color the label
and not that's another option that's
another case
if there is a frame label you could
color the frame label or you could put a
swatch by the frame label
rather than coloring the axis
i mean that makes sense to me to do a
swatch i think it looks pretty ugly to
actually color the frame label itself
it doesn't look that bad
ah
well that's another option but but
certainly when there are frame
labels
i mean there are plenty of cases where
there are anonymous curves
i think that all these cases are
relevant i mean there's cladding with a
frame label there's the color the frame
label there's a swatch with the frame
label
why don't you just describe all of those
and let's call this
um
i mean i i hate to call it multi-axis
options but i wonder whether there's a
better because that way
i mean the the more consistent thing
will be multi-axis rules
and then the answer
well what about rules because it's it's
basically
they're not
here what we could say in this
is we could have something where we say
um
you know in principle we can have a
complicated thing where we say
styling arrow
blah blah blah
i'm not sure i like this completely but
the left right thing yeah no no no no no
no
that's wrong because you definitely want
the possibility of just saying curve
one two whatever
um multi-axis
behavior multi-axis
rendering
what do we have that ends in styling
those are
not options there
directives basically yes
um
is there an axis style or axis style
there is an axis style
so why is it not in there
i think
that's a lot of stuff to put in there
potentially
well maybe we call it multi-axis
that's not no style is usually a style
setting
okay if you want to go deep you could
call it specification
if you want a whole sub language for for
doing it
let's not use the word specification
we've not used that anywhere
um what are some other things that we
might use multi-axis
i mean we have things are called actions
multi-axis what do we do in some of the
user um
the ui
appearance
those are usually very shallow
i mean a list of strings type thing
right
um
let's keep going and look at the rest of
what we have to look at here
do it
what this is
okay
you want one option to rule them all or
do you want multi-axis and
multi-axis
you know post fix to be determined
well i mean we could have multi-axis
style be its own thing
you know there is a certain argument for
that because you can set multi-axis
style once and for all
that's the styling you want
and then you could say multi-axis
what is the right thing and then the
second one is just where do you put what
i mean i would just say multiplex i mean
it could be position or
positioning or
but
all right and then and then it could be
true and false
in the simplest case you know what it's
not going to work to have the separate
styling because you're going to want to
specify this one uses cladding this one
uses a you know whatever they're all
kinds of crazy things like that you
might want
how far do we have to support crazy
well
i think it's just so long as we can
specified i don't think it's gonna be
hard to support it
what do you think about just a pure
multi-axis
i don't like that i don't like that it's
too
it needs an extra word
configuration
that can't be true or false
none can be known
well okay so multi-axis
we don't use the tone configuration
anywhere
i i sort of expect configuration to be a
permanent setting for something
arrangement none of those are very good
positioning
this that suggests positioning of the
axes
which it isn't it's it's the it's the
um
uh which curve goes with which
well
well i mean depends on which way you
look at it
um
i mean because you are sort of you know
specifying and you have your left right
you know syntax up there
so you really are saying where
the axis is going
um
which one are you saying arrangement
multi-axis configuration multi-axis
i i said positioning
i don't like it
that's gonna be above below those kinds
of things
okay
but we think that this is gonna this
this thing is gonna take both that
grouping where you don't say where you
just automation decides where
and
grouping plus
play plus location i mean plus where yes
and styling
oh and styling
well okay it's multi do you think it
needs to be something more than just
multi-axis goes to
i do i i think multi-access we're going
to regret using that name there because
i think we're going to need ultimately
we're going to need something called
multi-axis plot or some such other thing
and we're going to want to have used
that word
um
why do i have this it's under
visualization
gosh when are we going to have the
visualize function
okay
let's okay we got one name here which
you guys should try and think of
alternatives for let's just look at the
rest of what you have here okay okay
visualization scale support for
generalized scales
infinite scales what the heck does that
mean
it means
minus infinity to infinity type stuff
let's see what enough that does
um
so you're saying plot sine x
x goes from what 0 to 10 and then what
plot range no just minus infinity to
infinity
what the heck is that going to do
it's going to plot sine x from minus
infinity to infinity
when are we going to have it be able to
be automatic and use warfarin alpha
style
point region of interest stuff
well we'll we'll
we should we should get that that that
capability i think it exists in wolfgang
a notebook edition
what on earth is this doing
it's
it's plotting it from minus infinity to
plus you can see that but how is it
doing that what kind of scale basically
a scaling function that is you know
around rescale of you know
minus infinity infinity to minus one to
one
what is it like is it logarithmic is it
reciprocal go to
go to scaling functions new reference
page
i don't think it has the actual formula
yet but
i hope it does
scaling functions new
have a picture a little bit further down
okay so it doesn't have them yet
i think the default infinite scale i
think that's the one that i used for
the models of infinity right
uh
no i think we're using
rescale instead of your okay fine uh
yours
right i think that the main issue when
you want these sort of compactifications
is to
um you know what range do you kind of
want to
emphasize yeah
and that stretch is not properly it's
not fully
we i think we agreed to change that the
stretch
it needs to be an interval basically
where you want to
uh see it okay so wait a minute so so
yours i mean
wow
i mean i hadn't thought of doing this
it's kind of interesting
do sine of x over x
that's really quite cool
isn't it
i've never seen this kind of thing
before
and you know in the in the old style
pen drawing you know yankee md days i
don't think anybody did this there
either it's a new idea
it's an interesting idea i mean
obviously we see here
this function i should be able to figure
it out what it is based on the fact that
those peaks are going down linearly
right so those peaks are equally spaced
and that means that
what does that mean i mean that that is
a good behavior in terms of scaling it
seems to me
i see that's a reciprocal
so for example if i did over x squared
x cubed
probably one plot range at all
well maybe not
i take that back
oh look what i want to do but that's not
gonna sine x cubed right that's what i
should have yeah yes yes
okay
i guess you don't want that um well no
that's fine i mean it's amusing but now
well wow i mean i've never seen this
type of thing
um
that's cool
i mean i'm not sure i have any
particular comment of them that looks
like it's working quite nicely i mean
what would happen if i went
uh if i said on here
plot range
arrow
minus infinity to infinity
ah we can't do that yet
um
well we can i think you have to i'm not
sure
if all the options are i think it's not
yeah for
this sort of thing but also
it's you know by default it saw that you
had infinities
in your x ranges and so it's
auto switched to you know
the scaling function for the x direction
for that but not for the y
okay fine
all right i want to ask about
categorical scales now let's talk about
that next time we want to we want to not
do that now
what's the basic idea though
the basic idea is to remap it to a
quantitative scale
okay
fine
uh in which case we have 100 plots that
all of a sudden can plot categorical
data
but so what you mean by that is
cat is one dog is two bird is three
type stuff
no i understand it i'm just thinking
what does that mean for
so you're saying
that in a list plot
i can be you know
cat dog bird cat cat cat dog dog or
heads tails whatever yeah or you can
combine sort of cat comma you know 1.3
dog
you know you can have quantitative and
categorical they don't need to be both
categorical both quantitative
no i understand it but i'm asking if the
y-axis is categorical then what you'll
see is
as a function of x you'll see the thing
bouncing around between cat and dog
right
i think that this is very compelling but
we we didn't
i want to sort of it needs a little bit
more um
it doesn't feel complete yet it doesn't
feel complete yet we you know we already
brought it up for 12.3 but we want to
we want to
we we decided to go with these other
scales
uh first
as we were overhauling the whole scaling
and axis kind of frameworks to be able
to do this
so infinite scales
but also date scales um anywhere
okay this was a comment from jack
so
make label specifications more
consistent and simple
so um what was the comment
well
it's about
label scales
boy that's somebody using the transpose
that's cool
don't see that very often
i like it all the time
that looks like a transposy thing yeah
absolutely that's how you get compact
nice code
oh
okay
um
all right but anyway so the question
here is
why didn't this work
i
don't know off the top of my head
looks like a bug to me
indeed
okay
all right just pick it up as a bug yep
i'm gonna screenshot it so
okay
so the other thing that you know is
related to the scaling functions
is you know
we're supporting
dates
in more places
good about time too
so if you so if i do a time series and
throw it into list line plots if i say
something like um
uh
battles in the civil war
or is this going to be a really
disastrous idea
um and then i say
um
my god
it's what happens
i guess okay so now we say what is that
what on earth is that
okay can somebody report that as a bug
please that's a horrible bug
yes
okay
my gosh what is that that's some idiotic
thing
looks like a bad scrape of some sort
and that's very dead as well
oh dear we're crashing here
okay anybody know what the um
it should auto complete
oh for god's sake somebody completely
broke this
growl
this is prototype right at least
this is deeply broken
just grab a time series from somewhere i
know i'm trying to get a time series
where do i get a time series from a
rough time series
okay
that was really broken
however it's encouraging that the
caching infrastructure looks like it's
got nice blue boxes and things
that's cool
okay there we go
and now let's say here
um
how do we get the time values of this we
get um
do you want the dates either date value
property or
what is it
maybe because i have the name wrong
well yeah
this is horrible but
let's do this
okay so now what you tell me is if i say
list plot of that
i get that great
but that should work right
that
is do
scaling functions goes to date
so i don't think it's auto i mean we're
not auto detecting
um
we should
strengthen that for geo position
date
like this
one
is this prototype build
yes
yeah it's prototype build
are you sure it's just called date well
okay so there's something wrong there is
something i think you should be able to
detect this is so
i'll
we'll look at whether we can auto detect
that um but an example that should
definitely work is if you just do
this line plot of that time series
okay
well so you're saying we can get rid of
dateless plots essentially
but we're not a moment too soon
but now dateless plot has all kinds of
detailed settings for the dates
how will that work for
this plot
so
the
ultimate way is we introduce something
called date scale
yeah one ultimate way
is we
also introduce something that is
sort of the scaling function setting
that allows you to
control
you know sort of detailed how
um
that goes on
okay but i i don't even see okay here
delta t in the date spec
can be any of those
so that's like sort of a data range type
thing
i think so
but those are the things we need to get
i mean like like the this you know
specifying quarters and things like that
those are super useful things
right we haven't really i think fine
we'll go back to that but that actually
kind of fits in with the date scale idea
for scaling functions
and the other thing one of the killer
things here is that this will work for
list plot 3d and list contour plot sure
and you'll be able to have a date access
for those that's really nice
right it's really nice think of
combinatorially how many cases
that we can no i know i know this is
wonderful
right
same goes for these infinite axis by the
way
magnificent that that analysis thing's
really cute
um
okay i think we're is this is this as
far as we can get here we've still got a
few bits of cleanup to do on this
right okay
do you wanna return
i think we should i mean given that once
you have these things ready you're going
to have these things no no that's going
to be for 13.1
okay all right fine
is state scale going to be ready yes
okay and we're going to have to return
on that we'll have to return maybe we
can put it together with some other
cleanup design reviews we'll probably
have some loose ends from some other
things let's see if we can combine them
sounds good okay and i believe we have
another live stream coming up right now
with
spatial statistics
okay
and
is it the same place same place or
well i think it was a different place i
think we should go to the different
place okay see
so those on who are following us on our
live stream please um we'll be back with
you in just a moment
um